hello friends this week I'm sitting down
with William von Hippel who is a
professor of psychology at the
University of Queensland in Australia
his works been covered in the Australian
New York Times The Economist Harvard
Business Review Time magazine and The
Sydney Morning Herald amongst many of
the publications and on top of that
William von Hippel sounds like a baron
from medieval times which is it's the
sickest name ever so I first came across
spills work when I heard him on Joe
Rogan's podcast a couple of weeks ago
and I was absolutely fascinated very
fortunately we've managed to find a slot
in Bill's book to which he's currently
undergoing in America and I managed to
sit down with him to go through his new
book the social leap the new
evolutionary science of who we are where
we come from and what makes us happy if
you have ever wondered about how great
apes in trees became bipedal beings out
on the plains and then evolved into the
humans that you see before you today
this podcast is really for you there's a
beautiful story element and a narrative
behind what bill talks about plus
there's loads of implications for how we
operate today again the same as with my
podcast I did with Professor Robin
Hanson the elephant in the brain why we
are the way we are nowadays is not due
to the environment that we evolved in
but in other news I have got some
messages about why there wasn't a
podcast up on audio platforms last week
and if you do not follow me on social
media you may not know why however we
didn't know the YouTube exclusive what
it's really like starring on take me out
after the what's really like on love
island podcast we decided to double down
if it ain't broke don't fix it sure
enough the podcast has taken off really
quickly and it's been covered by some of
the UK press which is always good news
despite them misquoting me and one of
them misspelling my name but whatever
it's fine but we're back on a schedule
I've got Joanie and Youssef coming up
very very soon to do some special
edition Christmas podcasts I've also got
the
the fattest thickest longest section of
recording that I've ever had to do in
the build-up to Christmas so you may
even get to a week over the Christmas
holidays but don't hold me to it in the
meantime we're gonna find out why we are
the way we are and where we came from oh
yeah
PS the first minute and a half might
sound slightly different to normal I was
still fighting with Skype at this point
but don't worry I was victorious normal
audio services resumed after a couple of
minutes
[Music]
professor William von Hippel how are you
today good very happy to be here very
happy to have you on it's been a
technological catastrophe so far but it
would appear that we've managed to tame
all of the electronics that we're using
to get this call to work which I'm
really really happy about so thank you
for that I've totally my place where
I've got high hopes
so the social leap you are currently on
your book tour that's right that's right
amazing so the social leap
what is it so that's the term I use for
the kind of solution that our ancestors
came to when they left the rainforest
and were forced to move to the savanna
and so you know here they were these
sort of chimp-like creatures who were
really at the top of the food chain when
they're in the canopy but we're very
vulnerable on the ground and so how did
they solve that problem well I think it
took a few million years of sort of
skulking around the edge of the savanna
but eventually and I believe by the time
we got Telstra Pittacus they had learned
to cooperate and band together in their
mutual defence and so I call this the
this leap from the trees to the savanna
and then this increasing sociality that
are came with that leap and that in fact
I believe started off our entire
evolutionary process that brought us to
where we are now that's what I call the
social leap amazing what was the process
of researching a book before we get into
it what was the shirt is it a lot of
deductive reasoning is it another sense
of well there's a lot of really fabulous
archaeology and paleoanthropology and
other forms of anthropology that people
have done to try to make inferences
about where we came from what were the
cognitive capabilities of our ancestors
and their social lives like and you know
there's not much to work with when
you're looking at fossils that are
millions of years old
and hey but but these people have done a
fabulous job of trying to infer
cognitive abilities in the deep past and
all I did was really come along and read
this literature I've got a wonderful
colleague set of colleagues at UQ who
are expert in these areas and we all we
have these fortnightly meetings where we
hash it out we've been doing that for
about the past dozen years
I only get two yeah fine I get to the
point where I felt like okay I I think
I've got the story figured out and it
makes sense to me how it sits with our
modern psychology I think it's time to
try to tell that story fantastic so
let's start the story then why does it
begin so it begins six or seven million
years ago we don't know exactly of
course but basically the story is as the
tectonic activity in the great African
Rift Valley increased you got a lot of
upwelling on the east side of the roof
Alley as I gather it's a bit of thinness
in the crust or a hot spot or something
that's a result of the two plates
tearing apart or the single plate
becoming two plates you know starting up
at the Red Sea and working its way down
to the coast of Mozambique so the whole
right side of that Ethiopia Kenya
Tanzania um vast areas of the air you
know today about a mile up and what that
appears to have done is caused the
rainforest to slowly dry out with the
end result that our ancestors had very
little choice but to move to the savanna
because the simply wasn't enough forest
left for them to make a living right
okay so that move it must have been very
biologically expensive and very
vulnerable for a while absolutely I mean
I I suspected it was devastating and
that we you know if you replayed that a
dozen times I bet you that 11 times out
of 12 all you get are a bunch of dead
chimp like animals but somehow we got
lucky and and you can look at cues of
how we got lucky by looking for example
that the chimpanzees in Senegal who live
on the savanna and by looking of course
said Savannah baboons and other primates
who've chosen to live on the ground I
suspect that the the chimps in in
Senegal are great choice because if you
look at what they do they basically do
the kinds of things that I would imagine
our ancestors would have done which is
sort of skulk around the margins try to
keep a tree inside at all times and make
a break for it whenever you know a
predator comes along because leopards
lions hyenas all those would now be an
enormous threat yeah despite the fact
that when they were in the trees they
were not a threat at all yeah I get that
completely so is there any crossover of
chimps moving towards
those chimps actually moving towards the
development that we heard well I don't
think so and the they don't they don't
they do [ __ ] well I shouldn't say that
they're showing some very interesting
early signs that look a little bit like
what I suspect that we did so for
example they tend to share a little bit
better than chimps typically do they
they're the only chimps that we know of
that sharpen sticks into spears by
biting them and then use those Spears to
stab and retrieve monkeys that they eat
these Bush babies out of tree hollows
mm-hmm and and they even sleep in caves
so there's some very interesting things
that they do but I actually think that
the the shift that mattered was one that
probably took a few million years and
that was an animal that was now
exclusively living in the savanna and
had become by people and bipedality in
my mind we can talk about where that
came from but in my mind it played a
critical role in leading to us because
it changed the body of our ancestors
from one that wasn't not a very
effective body at throwing to one that
was now very effective at throwing by
virtue of the long longer whim aced by
virtue of the muscles no longer being so
vertically oriented in the chest and
shoulders and being more lateral and by
virtue of greater flexibility in the
wrists because they weren't using it
their hands as a platform to climb trees
as much all of those things would have
enabled much more effective throwing
okay why is throwing so important so
throwing is probably the most important
military invention of all time say I
know that sounds outlandish but not per
se but rather the capacity to kill at a
distance right so no other animal has
that capacity and that capacity is
mission-critical to enable a larger
force of weaker individuals to overcome
a smaller force of stronger ones so if
you and I were and our friends we're on
the Savannah and a lion came along and
we wanted to attack it imagine we're all
armed with knives yeah and there's
enough of us we could kill the thing but
we know full well that whoever goes in
first is gonna be lying yeah we'd all be
going you I'm after you Chris yes well
you can go further exactly and so but
once we could throw now we could attack
the lion or defend ourselves from a lion
at a safe distance and especially if
there's enough of us all throwing stones
at the same time now we're in a position
to actually do great damage to the line
without suffering any damage to
ourselves right okay so that that sounds
a lot to me there's a show on Netflix in
the UK called the evolution of us have
you seen this or heard of this I haven't
this house very interesting though so it
sounds an awful lot like the story that
you're going through at the moment and
on it they had got monkeys they'd
attached attached different microscopic
dots that can be tracked by a computer
and then they tracked their walking gait
when they walked on a treadmill I'm one
of the one of the big differences that
they highlighted between those monkeys
and us was the size of our glutes the
the monkeys essentially don't have any
glutes in comparison with us it's the
biggest muscle in our body right and
right that capacity for us to be able to
stand up straight and to be able to run
long distances they they highlighted
this really big difference because when
you watch a monkey walk on two legs it's
pretty unwieldly isn't it it moves it
moves super weird it doesn't look like
it was meant to do that and I guess
that's because it's not yeah that's
right so chimps and apes you know and
monkeys in general can't lock their
knees they have no need to be able to do
that and so their whole body isn't
shaped properly for walking on two legs
of course they can do it and especially
if when you see them in water they tend
to do it and occasionally they just do
it for other reasons but by the time we
get to Australopithecus we were bipedal
and so there's those famous footprints
quite know how to pronounce of Laetoli
footprints that Mary Leakey if I
remember I found and they when you
computer model of those footprints you
can see that the foot strike is of an
animal that had locked its knee and
therefore its full weight was coming
down on steel something that a
chimpanzee can't do and so that makes
the big good reason why our ancestors
would have become bipedal it obviously
would have taken a while one of those
reasons is probably this notion that you
were just discussing the idea of
persistence hunting that it's it
requires fewer calories to run long
distances on
two legs at a slower pace to chase down
antelope and other animals that will
sprint as hard as they can and then soon
enough become exhausted and can be
killed so many people have argued that
that's part of the reason why we became
bipedal and I suspect that's true any
changed that's that big is highly likely
to have multiple causes
I think that that was an advantage of
bipedality my personal view is that's
not what caused it will caused is
probably psychological factors and but
the outcome of those of that change was
now an animal it's much more effective
at throwing and and of course the key to
throwing is if you imagine one
Australopithecus throwing rocks at a
lion well it's gonna end up in the belly
of a slightly bruised and annoyed lion
but if you imagine fifty
australopithecines throwing rocks and
lion and now you get a world where you
could conceivably drive it away and so
there would have been enormous
evolutionary pressure on these ancestors
to learn to work together in a way that
chimpanzees simply can't do and that
increased sociality and cooperativeness
then would have kicked into a gear all
sorts of forces that led to our brain
expansion and led to where we are today
okay so you mentioned psychological
factors that you thought that was the
reason that we moved to bipedality what
are those so if you look at chimpanzees
they're incapable of planning for
unfilled needs so if if it's hungry now
it can plan to like maybe grab a branch
it'll go over to a shrub it'll grab a
branch it'll strip the leaves off and
then walk over to the termite mound and
dip it in and fish out for termites and
so in that sense it's planning for a
felt need it's hunger and its desire to
eat termites but once it's finished
fishing for termites they can't imagine
that we'll ever be hungry again and so
it literally throws the stick away and
and off he goes and of course there's
lots of experiments that do that in a
more controlled fashion where you find
that exact effect that it simply is
incapable of considering the fact that
it might be hungry again or anything
else now if you look at our ancestors
like us australopithecines there's no
sign that they either could plan for
unfelt needs now of course that's super
hard to know right they've been gone for
millions of years but the one thing the
chimpanzees couldn't do it and then
when we get after Australopithecus we
get to Homo habilis and the tools that
they made these Oldowan tools which are
very slightly sharpened stones and some
people argue that australopithecines
were sharpening stones as well there's
some controversial evidence about that
but either way there's the the tools
that either Australopithecus made or
that Homo habilis made have never been
found at any great distances from where
they're acquired and made and what that
suggests is an animal that's making a
tool for its immediate use and then
literally leaving it behind now it's
possible of course that it's easier to
make a new one than it is to schlep it
with you we don't know oh by the time we
get to homo erectus they're making a
much nicer tool it's by facial it's
really they're shoeing tools are really
quite lovely and they're carrying them
to great distances so we know at least
by the time we get to the next species
down the chain from Homo habilis we know
that we've got an animal that can
envision unfelt needs you know I've used
this tool now I'm gonna want it again
tomorrow so then the question is how is
that tied to bipedality yeah well if
you're a and also if you're a chimp like
creature in the savanna
and you're setting out across the grass
for food or for whatever purpose you and
and you cannot envision unfelt needs
some people have said well maybe they
develop bipedality in order to carry a
weapon or to carry food well that's not
super plausible in the sense that
they're not trying to prepare for the
future if if an Australopithecus was
hungry it would eat the food it's not
hungry it would leave it behind because
it won't envision being hungry again so
then you have to ask yourself well what
might an Australopithecus feel what
would be its felt need every time it's
set out across the savanna and I think
it's super clear that you imagine
yourself this you know three and a half
foot tall guy setting out across the
open grass I think you're gonna feel
fear because any you know you're just
you're just available for any major
predator any large cat or dog that's out
there yeah and so if you're felt need
every time you set out across the
savanna was fear then what you would
probably want with you is some sort of
weapon so if chimpanzees today who live
on the savanna can chew a stick and make
a sharp point I'm sure our
Australopithecus ancestor could do the
same thing
they had slightly larger brains than a
chimp and so my guess is that they're
fashioning a crude spear or club or even
stone and they want to carry it with
them every time they set out across the
savanna now they may need to make a new
one every morning because when they get
home they don't think they'll ever need
it again yeah but every time they set
out they're gonna look for something
like that and that of course will be a
psychological pressure toward bipedality
because it's much easier to carry a
spear or some other sort of weapon if
you can walk on two legs
I get that I get that so why go out on
the plains at all well because the trees
are disappearing you're in the no choice
condition you've got like five trees
that you're sitting in but there's
nothing beat there yeah and so if you
want to find food if you want to you
know get to another stand of trees where
there might be other safety and other
things to eat you got to move along
right totally
you mentioned brain size differences in
brain size there and also obviously
there'll be big differences in
physiology what are the differences
between the closest relative that we've
got and the Australopithecus in terms of
brain size and then in terms of
structure so the Australopithecus has
about a 450 gram brain and the
chimpanzees about 380 so you've got
about three million years on the
Savannah has given you about 70 grams of
brain that's not a whole lot of big
investment but not a lot right right
well I think that that's I think there's
good reason for that and I think that
good reason is is that brains are super
expensive you know we just think of them
as an unmitigated good because they can
do so much for us
but until we live in a world where you
have a purpose for your brain you're
paying a big price in calories our brain
uses 20% of our metabolic energy at all
time so that's a big cost and what
return are you getting on that
investment well as the chimpanzee what
are you gonna do it's a little more
brain it's not it's not clear when you
don't cooperate with each other when you
don't work together well it's not
entirely clear that you're gonna gain
something to offset the losses part of
the reason for that of course is that
they don't have control of fire and so
they can't release nearly as many
nutrients from their food as we can so
Richard Wrangham talks about that is
wonderful book Catching Fire how
basically in order to develop the big
brain that we have that's supported by
such a small gut you need to be eating a
lot of me then you need to be really
releasing as many Cal
from it as possible as many nutrients as
possible which is achieved by cooking
because raw food simply is I mean you
can just you can tell just by the sense
of smell if you if you sniff a steak
that's cooking up nicely it smells
beautiful it's assuming you like to
taste to me if you sniff a raw steak it
just doesn't smell beautiful at all no
and and the same holds for a potato a
raw potato is inedible Oh cook potato
smells and tastes delicious and so
that's our that's our evolved
understanding of what's nutritious for
us and what's not yeah I really wanted
to touch upon this the way that I think
a lot of modern humans if you don't look
into evolutionary biology sweet things
taste sweet because they're sweet is
kind of like breakfast sentence right
but that's not the case
well no not because our ancestors were
constantly in search of salt sugar and
fat those are the three things that
allow us to survive and that are in
short supply on the Savannah in the
jungle anywhere else and so but we lived
in a world where there was never enough
of those things and so we didn't evolve
a psychology that says well I only know
a little bit we evolved the psychology I
want to get as much of it as I can and
so it's super hard to stop eating that
stuff because our ancestors never
worried about eating too much of it so
the McDonald's hacking of sweet food and
salty food and all this sort of stuff
the binging when it when you're binging
away on some fast food it's actually a
primitive brain that's kicking in saying
this is good for you you should have
more of this because there's not going
to be much around right it's is that but
I would actually caveat that ever so
slightly by saying that we have evolved
to get full when we eat a lot of meat
because protein is the one signal that
we it's it's the one food source that we
the macronutrient that we really search
out because we protein you know our
bodies are built to protein and we need
to get enough protein in our diet in
order to survive and so humans and
crickets and all the other animals that
have been tested basically use protein
as a guide to indicate when they're full
and this is really beginning with
wonderful research by Steve Simpson
who's a biologist spent much of his
career at Oxford and is now at Sydney
University and since
schon he's got a wonderful book the
nature of nutrition he's shown very
clearly that if you vary the protein
levels in food animals will weigh over
eat carbohydrates in order to get enough
protein but they wait they won't weigh
over eat proteins in order to get enough
carbs protein seems to be the limiting
factor and I do believe that the way it
works is that it makes you feel full and
so when you eat a you know a hamburger
or McDonald's or a steak or something
like that you go I feel so full whereas
if you sit down with a box of cereal I
mean I could literally eat a box of
cereal while I'm watching television and
not even feel it no but all lately and
I'll have consumed way more calories and
I would get out of Big Mac or a steak or
something like that why is there this up
assailing on the protein intake do you
think well so think about our ancestors
they would have so today they get lucky
and they kill a draft for their gonna
stuff is much giraffe down their pile as
they can but they're gonna get to a
point where I can't eat any more of this
I'm feeling super full they would have
only very rarely been in a situation
where there's so much carbohydrate that
a tasted very good and B they wanted to
eat and so there's just gonna be little
evolutionary pressure on them to detect
that they're full from carbs but a great
deal of evolutionary pressure to be able
to say all right well now I'm saying
that I've had enough protein amazed and
interesting interestingly the data also
suggests that part of that is driven by
lack of variety and so if you serve
there's some interesting work with a
music's people who have such dense
amnesia they won't even remember five
minutes ago and they'll interestingly
they'll eat a second lunch if you serve
them lunch and then leave and come back
and say lunchtime they'll eat it again I
mean it is it is a mean experiment but
it's interesting because the what's
happening there is that the part of our
sense of being full is actually our
knowledge that we ate and because they
don't have that knowledge they don't
have that sense of as strong of a sense
of being full and but what's interesting
is that if you give them less variety
like you say well here's the one food
that you leave for lunch these
sandwiches they don't want those
sandwiches anymore again suggesting that
we've evolved sera they've had enough
giraffe I'm not gaining anything from
this I don't feel like eating it anymore
I get that there's a competitive eaters
that are in ice-cream competitions they
yeah offset the ice-cream with french
fries because they're you'd want to do
something out to allow yourself to keep
going although I personally can't
imagine doing that but but it makes good
evolutionary sense fine if the
evolutionary psychologists and
biologists say that it's okay than the
competitive eaters the competitive
eaters have got it right so Australia
Australopithecus is now on the edge of
the plains
maybe developed some tools and this
level of cohesion within the group and
they can I guess really rudimentary
tactics to take down prey
what where do we move from there what do
we roll forwards onto from there great
questions so now here we are with this
animal that's barely getting any brain
power but is bipedal and has a capacity
to throw and probably has the
psychological understanding that we need
to work together and a tendency a you
know preference to cooperate because of
course evolution works by what you want
to do more so than by a knowledge GI off
to do this and that knowledge would have
been hard for such an animal anyway so
you now have got a more cooperative
animal that is sort of working together
on the savanna and that actually opens
up all sorts of potential benefits to
get smarter because once we're working
together well we could have we can
imagine division of labor now we can be
a much more effective squad if you go
left I go right and someone else attacks
down the middle we could bring down this
animal and we could have it for dinner
and so all sorts of emergent properties
come from groups that can envision what
each other are thinking they can find a
way to work together they can plan for
the future that can do all these sorts
of things so it whereas in the past
getting smarter would have been very
little use now getting smarter is of
great benefit so there's some really
interesting work that came out recently
on notch to NL gene which is a gene for
brain expansion and what the what the
day it's new data but what they suggest
is that this gene likely appeared in our
line maybe twelve million years ago and
the way it did is that it accidentally
duplicated itself but then this new
version was turned off so to speak
now evolution often works this way
because if you've duplicated a gene
unintentionally you know in some in the
in
in the process of meiosis or wherever if
there's an actual accidental duplicate
copy now you can do things with that
duplicate without disrupting the
function that the original did because
it's an extra so you can just play
around with it so to speak and so this
this extra gene seems to have emerged
212 million years ago or so in our line
and about 3 million years ago around the
time of Australopithecus it seems to
have duplicated itself again and turned
back on now my guess is that it turned
back on many times randomly between 12
million years ago and 3 million years
ago but whoever got that extra gene
turned back on didn't gain much from it
the cost of that of the extra brain
wasn't outweighed by the benefits but
now you get to these social animals
these australopithecines who are working
together and now the benefits of being
smarter can outweigh the cost because we
can gain emergent properties from our
group if we can work together better and
so you see rapid brain expansion so
remember out the first three million
years gained us maybe 70 grams of brain
now you go from Australopithecus to homo
erectus you're moving about 1 million
years and you go from about 450 to about
960 grams so more than doubling a brain
size now admittedly Homo erectus is
bigger so it's in this cut it's more of
a relative issue but it's still a big
change and then you go from homo erectus
to us and you we're now at about 1350 so
they've essentially added an entire
chimp brain onto Homo erectus in the
last million and a half years or so so
massive brain expansion that accompanied
the greater the sociality that we gained
on the savanna and that enabled us to
suddenly become much more effective than
we have been before so is brain size
equal to power is that the way that it
works yeah basically I mean the you know
it's complicated of course because
elephants have ginormous brains and to
the best of our knowledge they haven't
built great cities or done any of those
things of course they don't have hands
but they do a fabulous trunk yeah um but
so it's it's it's an issue it's a it's
an issue we don't fully understand but
there's no question that the larger
brain gives you much more computing
power right and then you've said as
you've mentioned a really clever giraffe
or a really clever zebra has an upper
limit on what the use is and it's
actually a very
expensive cost to have that bridge to
have to consume all of those extra
calories but you you are given more
capacity to utilize that brain when you
are able to work together in a group and
you said Homo erectus 2 million years
ago is that right
yeah a little less okay and then where
did they go from there how do we think
that they move forward well so homo
erectus we can see signs that they
actually can plan for the future so
remember I talked about how they carried
their tools around we also see some
really interesting evidence that they
work together really well with division
of labour so for example in making those
tools there's a site in India that's 1.2
million years ago that carry Shipton is
written about and he talks about how as
you look at the site you can see that
the original pieces of rock that they
want to fashioned into a tool are
knocked loose in one location and then
maybe 10 meters over to the right there
originally worked on for a little bit to
get them into the right basic form and
then maybe 10 more meters over there now
doing the final sharpening well if one
that if one Homo erectus is making the
tool why would it break it loose here
walk 10 meters work on a little bit more
systematically walk another 10 meters
and work on it more it probably wouldn't
break it loose and sit down but if but
if people are working together if the
home erectus knocks it loose hands it to
his mate who's better at at the second
stage and he hands it to a friend who's
better at that final stage well it would
make sense that it's systematically
being done at certain spatial locations
around the site so it's pretty good
evidence for division of labour it's a
primitive primitive henry fold yeah
that's exactly right it's like a little
factory right and and then we see
evidence that so for example up by the
Sea of Galilee there's a wonderful just
an anecdote but it's an interesting one
where an elephant has has either been
killed or scavenged and the Homo erectus
who were working that we see a bunch of
hand axes there are Shu lien tools lying
around and we see the head has been
broken loose from the neck and turned
over now brains are a wonderful source
of fat because the myelin sheath around
the neurons you know that's so brains
are very very high in fat and
cholesterol but remember that's what
everybody's seeking all the time and of
course it'd be a lot easier to get into
I'm
and sprains through the base of its goal
than trying to break this goal through
the top yeah because there's such
massive item well you could imagine a
thousand chimpanzees crawling all over a
mammoth skull it's they're never gonna
effectively turn it over because they
can't work together but Homo erectus
you know everybody heave on three kind
of thing you could imagine that's
working together effectively to achieve
something that they couldn't do
individually and so examples like these
suggest that by the time word Homo
erectus we're now super effective we're
using our brain power to accomplish
things that we could never accomplish
individually because we can work
together as a group we can divide up
tasks and we can even plan for these
future activities like a hunt you know
you guys come over here we'll we'll try
to get the horses to run down this this
way here and we'll dig a trap and we'll
capture and kill them and there's
evidence that they were eating horses
and elephants even massive elephants
much bigger than today's throughout
Europe
so megafauna elephants were being felled
by humans who had a brain that was 2/3
the size of ours but they were sickly
there was so much more capable of
working together that that's right we
don't know for sure that they're
bringing them down right the all we can
see is maybe they were scavenging them
but I think the data suggests that they
were hunting them so if you look at at
the marks of the tools on the bones you
can see lots of marks where if they were
scavenging like the up high on the leg
near the torso when when animals hunt
other animals they always eat that
region first and yet we see lots of
marks on the bones up in the upper thigh
bone where you wouldn't be working with
your stone tools if you were scavenging
someone else's killed because the beans
already got there to eat yeah so I think
the data suggests pretty strongly I know
this controversial some thought
everybody would agree but I think they
suggest pretty strongly that Homo
erectus is now moving back to the top of
the food chain
and the doing that via their capacity to
cooperate and work together fascinating
that's so it's so interesting what are
the what are the tribe sizes that we
think at this saw a stage wow that's a
great question I don't know the they're
probably much smaller than what we see
today there's a lot of argument about
what's the optimal tribe size in humans
even to
a-and people have given numbers like 150
and and it is the case that humans are
quite capable of processing the
interrelationships of 150 other humans
and Robin Dunbar has lots of nice
evidence showing that but in actuality
when you look at hunter-gatherer groups
they very rarely are in anywhere near
that size the preferred size is much
closer to 20 or 30 because when you get
groups to large everybody starts to
bigger you know we've got a world with
all sorts of laws and rules and and all
sorts of expectations that are formally
laid down that prevent that kind of
arguing and bickering and we're less
interdependent so you know if I don't
get along with my neighbor it's not
ideal but I don't have to interact with
him all the time whereas if we're
hunter-gatherers and we're actually
working together every day on the hunt I
don't want to be with someone I don't
get along with and so groups tend to
splinter and break off into smaller
groups when that happens you and I
suspect you'll need one bad apple I
suppose done exactly well you know they
have good ways of getting rid of one bad
apple right because there's no laws
against it yeah and so you know bad
apples don't wake up one morning or they
when they do wake up everyone's gone but
if they're bad an Apple right but but
but it is the case that Homo erectus
probably had the exact same issues and
so they're probably traveling around in
small groups that are a combination of
family and close friends and they're
probably doing you know chimps and
humans both are what they call these
sort of fission fusion groups where
larger groups come together and then
they break off and go their separate
ways and they wreak um together so long
as they're members in the same
overarching group and so I don't know
what Homo erectus is language
capabilities were if they had any it may
have been all gestural it may have been
spoken we don't we don't yet know but
there would have been even if it's
gestural they'll be meanings in some
places that aren't quite the same as
others and so there's probably in-groups
and out-groups among Homo erectus just
like there aren't chimpanzees and just
like there are in humans that's
fascinating that there would be
essentially different languages and
dialects of these gestural communication
tools you could potentially have someone
from another tribe that's really really
far away that comes in and you
essentially can't communicate I know
that sounds stupid considering whether
next to France and I can't speak to a
friend right but it could be very
similar I mean there's gonna be some
basic gestures that everyone understands
but you know it's always the case that
when you travel in a foreign country
we'll say don't use that gesture that's
a rude one here even though it's a
positive one where you're from yeah and
I see no reason why that hasn't always
been the case that's fascinating I
recently did a podcast with Professor
Robin Hanson who wrote the elephant in
the brain yeah it was a great podcast I
enjoyed that thank you
oh yeah it was um I found that so
fascinating what I really loved I wanted
to dip in there if any of the listeners
haven't heard that he had an
evolutionary justification for gossip
and you mentioned about the one bad
apple that gets left every evening and I
found it completely fascinating that he
spoke about the that bad apple that has
the social norms of the group and the
Fair Play gets its enforced via the fear
that the gossip is going to roust you as
being the bad apple so you want to add
ear to what the rules and the norms are
because if you don't you know everyone's
gonna find out about it I felt I thought
it was so interesting to hear that there
was a an evolutionary justification for
the watercooler
sure and and you know if you think about
it it makes perfect sense because we all
gossip we kind of looked down on it when
other people do it but we are so happy
to engage in it ourselves
oh really did you hear about so-and-so
and why is it so universally beloved to
do it because it because it plays such
an important role it's a way of managing
reputations and so if if I live in a
very small group where everybody is in
everybody's business and I start
misbehaving well the group can bring me
in line via gossip and and importantly
they can do it in a way that's very safe
so imagine that I'm the big tough guy in
our group and you and someone else are
worried about me and the way I'm
throwing my weight around you know you
can bring it up in a very offhand way
you know sort of along the lines of what
do you think a bill or not that would be
too direct you'd say oh I boy oh boy did
you hear what Bill did yesterday and if
the other person then responds with must
have been a wonderful thing he's a great
guy you know you shut your mouth but if
he says oh what was Bill up to you'd say
well I'm not totally sure what he meant
but he did this and then you can see if
the other person ratchets it up and says
well what a jerk
yeah and so Steve Pinker has this
wonderful um talk where he he talks
about our indirect uses of language
where for example when a police officer
stops you and you want to bribe him you
don't say hey can I bribe you you say
you know is there any way we could solve
this here and now
and you hope you'll say well if you give
me the fifty bucks I'll take care of
before even you give him the fifty and
drive off but of course if he says no
you have to pay the ticket you go okay
sorry I thought maybe that we could do
with this here now you could have that
kind of indirect language could be used
very easily in gossip if you're unsure
about the feelings of the person you're
talking to and unsure whether they're
gonna join your coalition and so gossip
is super important for managing
reputations and it's much safer way of
doing so than if you couldn't
communicate with the kind of complexity
that we're capable of there's only two
forms broadly two real forms of
communication isn't there there's words
or I guess written communication or body
language and there's violence that's it
that's right that's right and of course
one fails you got to do the other yeah
we've got this amazing communication
system that the other animals just don't
have and so you know we know that all
animals can communicate but if you look
at for example when chimps tried to
communicate what's going wrong or what's
going on and right they're very limited
and what they're able to get across to
each other and there's interesting cases
of female chimps trying to communicate
the danger they're in to their male
friends or partners and they just look
like what are you talking about whereas
human beings you know are one of the
most amazing things about being human is
the cumulative nature of our knowledge
and so because we can talk to each other
I can tell you about what happened when
that lion nearly ate me out by the
waterhole and now you know how to handle
it without ever going there yourself
yeah and that and every generation we
can build on the knowledge of the past
which enables you know we don't have to
reinvent the wheel and you know children
can learn what only geniuses knew just a
few generations ago because it becomes
part of our lower part of our way of
doing things totally right I guess that
combined with the ability to anticipate
felt needs is a that's right super
powerful and felt needs yes sorry is a
super powerful combination that's
absolutely right and so our
extraordinary communicative abilities
facilitate our groups and their capacity
to work together our
they're our capacity we call theory of
mine which is our understanding that the
contents of your mind are not equivalent
to the contents of my own so chimpanzees
can't do that bad they're not they're
partially aware but not fully aware of
the fact that what you know is different
from what I know because it requires
this ability to put myself in your shoes
that kind of perspective taking which is
actually very difficult humans don't
even get it till they're about four
years old but once you get that now not
only can you work together more
effectively because I know what you know
but you can communicate much more
effectively as well if you look at the
language of small children even when
they have the words sometimes they're
very hard to follow because they don't
know what you know and don't know and
they start a story in the middle once
you know once you've got theory of mind
once I know what you know and don't know
as a function of what you saw on what
you heard and all the rest I can much
more effectively communicate with you I
can we can divide up our tests much more
effectively and I can also teach you
much better because I know what you know
and what you don't know so I know where
to start when I'm trying to teach you
that which our group does you know to
kill the elephant or whatever it is that
must also tie into lying then I'm gonna
guess and deceit the absolutely theory
of mind can you explain how that works
together yes absolutely so so other
animals are deceptive you know all
across the animal kingdom and even the
planking them and animals and plants
deceive each other by trying to look
like poisonous ones when they're not by
trying to disguise themselves etc but
when I say trying I don't mean
intentionally I just mean that's what
they evolved to do humans are the only
ones who can lie in the sense of
intentionally planting falsehoods in
someone else's mind and so you can
imagine that when you got theory of mind
you're the first organism to get it
nobody else has it you suddenly realize
well gee this is what everybody else
knows and here's what I know I can
benefit myself if I try to plant some
falsehoods in your mind that make me
look better than I really am and you
know when no one else knows that the and
no one else has that capacity it would
give you an enormous advantage so of
course everybody else involves that
capacity because it's so effective and
now what we see is children start to lie
as soon as they get to the point where
they have proper theory of mind now
they'll tell some very simple lies prior
like you say did you do this
and they know there's trouble Vogon oh
but that's just that's a very simple
kind of lie that doesn't really require
me to know the contents your mind it's
just me trying to give out a more
reactionary isn't it yeah exactly and
and and famously I'm Coco the gorilla
who penny worked with with the assign
language famously told her once when she
came into their trailer or whatever
wherever he was living and he had torn
Coco I guess she had torn the sink right
off the wall and and then claimed the
kitten did it and so and so it's a great
example of you know very simple I know I
didn't do that you know you see a cat he
did it which but wildly implausible
right yeah and so the little kids can do
that but once you get theory of mind now
you can start to plant some very
impressive lies and so the you know the
small children there's some wonderful
experiments where they'll teach them
theory of mind and then the kids start
to lie if it if it benefits them to
their advantage and so until you get
there you can't effectively lie because
you don't realize that what I know is
different from what you know so why
would you try to plant something in my
mind if you assume that our minds are
completely identical yeah
lying's are very complicated when you
when you break it down the fact that we
do it so naturally on a daily basis is
is more a byproduct of the way that we
operate as opposed to the fact that it's
simple it's an incorrect incredibly
complicated task to achieve so we're
Homo erectus we've moved on to the
plains where maybe you think tribes 20
to 30 something like that with some
proposal yes privet I think so
primitive communication tools why are we
going from there what's next yes so now
the question is um what happens now and
then how does it lead to where we are
today and one of the important things
that would have happened with Homo
erectus is and they're now they've moved
to the back to the top of the food chain
and so no longer is it the case that
saber tooth tigers or Lions or even
mammoths are important predators of
theirs anymore because as it as a group
they're so effective that although
occasionally individuals will be killed
by these large animals they're not
really a threat to the group writ large
but there is an important threat to the
group at large and that is other groups
of
rectus and so once you've got division
of labor and all these capacities really
the only threat to you is other groups
who have the same capacity and who might
be competing for the same resources and
so what that suggests is that we would
evolved in a psychology where we
cooperate really well with each other
right because that's what enabled us to
start defending ourselves in the
Savannah but we would not extend that
cooperative nature to other groups and
so Isis but we certainly know this holds
for Homo sapiens I suspect it goes back
to Homo erectus that they've now evolved
the tendency to be very cooperative
within their group but a group from the
outside may or may not be friendly it
may or may not be on their side or
against them and so they withhold
judgment and they don't necessarily
cooperate with them certainly not
automatically it's a potential
existential threat right that's right
and so that would have led to tribalism
ethnocentrism and all the kind of
genocidal tendencies that we see in
people today and the important thing to
remember is that the savanna made us
cooperative and friendly to each other
but it did that in order to make us more
effective killers so it's not a lovely
friendly thing without a negative side
at least from a moral standpoint what it
is is by becoming cooperative and kind
to each other our group works better and
can more effectively kill other animals
and potentially other members of our own
species as well that's so fascinating
that the the basis for tribalism you
know everyone everyone talks about
tribalism and this bipartisan politics
and this group versus that group and you
know but to actually find a
justification for why we are the way we
are that you know it makes so much sense
you wouldn't know absolutely what about
the de tribe from the other Valley what
if their wife their ill what if they
carry some some disease or some pathogen
or what if they you know I guess that's
yeah there's so many reasons as to why
we would be wearing right exactly right
in fact you the pathogen example is a
great one that's separate from our
possibility of competing over resources
and wanting to kill each other that's
where we're accidentally just killing
each other and as you get closer to the
equator there are more pathogens and
tribes tend to stay apart more for that
very reason because you know if you and
I live in Sweden and I'm
you live a thousand-mile a hundred miles
away chances are you and I have been
exposed to the same very few pathogens
that can survive in that environment but
if you and I live near the equator well
even if you're only a quarter-mile away
you may well have encountered pathogens
and have a resistance to them that I've
never seen and so if you and I mingle
you could make me sick and kill me
without ever may need to do so and as a
consequence I'm going to evolve a
tendency to stay away from you and of
course that's exactly what we see that's
so fascinating so what I'm what areas
are we talking about that are mostly
occupied by Homo erectus at this time I
think he said 1.2 million 1 million
years ago something like that where
where are we on the planet at the moment
ok so probably by 1.7 million years ago
Homo erectus have both stayed in Africa
and left
and so you see Homo erectus moving out
of you know through Arabia into Asia and
into Europe and they basically occupied
beginning around then and then extending
until Neanderthals who are their
offspring they've occupied the lower
half of Asia and they've occupied almost
all of Europe and of course they also
have colonized all of Africa and so
those Homo erectus who stayed in Africa
are they are the ancestors of Homo
sapiens so as homo erectus who moved out
of Africa are the eventual ancestors of
Neanderthals and so when Homo sapiens
leaves Africa we encounter Neanderthals
and as we now know we interbred with
them a few times and so we carry a fair
few means me and without genes as well
as some of the genes of other offshoots
of Homo erectus would left Africa and
lived in Asia at least it's like 2 to 5
percent right of our genes that's right
the under fits right and it's actually
higher it's higher in white populations
I think is that right as well right well
there's no evidence that Africans
interbred with Neanderthals because of
course Neanderthals didn't live there
yes and so everyone who left you know
worse Caucasians and Asians the every
non African in today's world is a small
subset of the groups at left Africa
beginning maybe 80 85 thousand years ago
and so those people appear to have left
and some took a right turn and
and work their way toward East Asia
system took a left turn and work their
way toward Europe and all of those
people seem to have interbred with
Neanderthals some of them also seemed to
have interbred with other subpopulations
that came from home erectus like the
Denisovans from that cave in Siberia we
know that some humans have some of their
genes and so but we don't we haven't
tested so many Africans yet to say with
any confidence that they don't have any
end of that genes but so far there
doesn't seem to be any and of course it
would make perfect sense that they don't
because they didn't leave Africa well
the Neanderthals as well would be very
unsuited to being in that environment
right that's right that's right and
given that we wiped them out or killed
them via disease or whatever when we
encountered them one can imagine that
those who did work the way toward Africa
didn't meet a friendly reception and
that didn't work out very well if it
ever happened absolutely in the Netflix
series that was discussing earlier on I
found it really fascinating where they
explained why we have different colored
skin they were talking about the melanin
that protects from the Sun and that when
you're closer to the equator that's more
important but as you get further north
that actually doesn't keep you as warm
and it was it seemed so so bizarre that
I'd never thought about it but the
distribution of body shapes and of
physiological makeup you know the Inuit
tribes and the people that are in the
north they tend to be smaller with high
levels of fat and then you've got you
know the best runners from the world all
come from Kenya like wow yeah this isn't
this isn't a surprise right right I mean
local ethnic groups adapt to the place
they live it's it's not a very sensible
thing to think about race which is such
a broad category that occurs to many
ethnic groups but if you think about
different ethnicities they make perfect
sense that they have to find a way to
make a living where where they are so my
younger brother is a biologist who works
up in the Bering Sea with a bunch of
Inuit groups trying to help them study
the consequences of these some
perchlorates and stuff that have been
left by the military that might be
cancer causing and so he was up there
one summer and way up in northern alaska
off the barren sea and the water is like
you know one or two degrees celsius and
they
and the local kids are running in and
playing and you know if you if you went
up to your ankles you nearly have a
cardiac arrest because it's just so cold
it's unbelievable but they've got this
sort of thin layer of subcutaneous fat
that protects them in a way that people
aren't in you just don't have yeah
that's so interesting
so when we're talking about these tribes
and stuff I really wanted to get on to
discussing sexual relationships and how
how partners and child-rearing worked
throughout the the timeline that we're
talking here would you be able to
explain some theories behind that to us
sure so the the child rearing and
partnering is complicated because human
beings are so behaviorally flexible that
we've got lots of ways that we do it but
there are some simple not simple there
are some underlying rules that apply to
all of us and and basically the
underlying rules stem from sexual
selection the notion that you know the
Darwin proposed that there you both have
to find a way to survive which is kind
of what we think of with natural
selection you know not dying when you
get attacked by a predator finding
enough to eat but you also have to find
a way to mate and if you don't find a
way to mate it doesn't matter how
fabulous you are those whatever traits
you have are not going to exist in the
next generation and so sexual selection
is that process of evolution that is
dependent on both our ability to attract
a member of the opposite sex and our
ability to compete with members of our
own sex in in order to do so so that
applies across the board and all humans
have been shaped by sexual selection
because we all have these traits that we
try hard to have these traits at others
opposite sex finds desirable and that we
that facilitate competition with their
own sex one of the interesting
psychological consequences of that is is
that we end up with this really
unfortunate circumstance whereby
everything is relative and what I mean
by that is that it doesn't really matter
how good of a guy I am what matters is
how do I compare to the other guys in my
group so if if all the men in my group
are sort of worthless lazy stupid and me
well it'll be pretty easy for me to get
a girl because I don't have to be very
special I can be pretty awful but I'm
still the best choice she has
whereas if if all the guys in my group
are really fabulous I'm stuffed
because she's never gonna choose me and
so in the end what people really care
about they're constantly looking around
and asking how they stack up compared to
others and the reason they do that is
it's super important for me not to fall
behind everybody else because if
everybody else in my group is better
doesn't matter how good I am I'm gonna
get left out of the mating game
and that's an unfortunate part of our
psychology because it virtually
guarantees in the modern world that it's
harder to be happy you know I can work
really hard to make a lot of money and
now I got more money than my this
neighbor but I then turn on the telly or
I meet somebody who's got more money
than I do and I'm upset all over again
yeah totally it puts us on this hedonic
treadmill to be constantly comparing
ourselves to others rather than just
having a set standard of what we want to
achieve yeah Alain de Botton from the
School of Life talks about confidence in
people being the highest identifier of
confidence in someone based on their
profession is the income and profession
of their same-sex parent right
interesting and that level of that level
of comparison but it's it's so it's so
well known it's cliche right keeping up
with the Joneses what is that exactly
exactly and so the thing is that if I
you know imagine that I invented a new
pill and it made you twice as smart I
gave it to you well instantly you'd feel
like you're some kind of genius right
because stuff you used to struggle with
it'd be easy for you now but imagine
that you then left your office and you
found out that I gave everybody two of
them and so you only had one everybody
else had two and now you'd feel like an
idiot literally seconds later because
there everybody else is discussing
things you can't understand yeah and so
sometimes comparisons make perfect sense
you need to be at the same level
everybody else's but ironically the same
thing also happens because of sexual
selection and domains that don't really
matter so imagine I told you look today
is your lucky day I'm gonna give you
just for being you $100,000 will you'd
be totally chuffed
until you left your office to brag about
it and you found out given everybody
else a million yeah and then suddenly
you'd be pissed off why did he only give
me on your grant well it's it's
ridiculous to feel that way because
you're 100,000 still buys you whatever
100,000 combined no matter what
everybody else has yeah but the logic of
sexual selection now makes you think oh
well if everybody else got a million I'm
gonna be left behind and and the girls
not gonna choose me is that and so is
that's that's an artifact of our sexual
selection processing that's hacking our
psychology for a whole lot of unrelated
or the other processes right well it is
it's an artifact that has both these
unfortunate consequences and also a
kernel of truth because if I if I do
give you on $2,000 you are more
attractive but you're not more
attractive if everybody else got a
million yeah that's totally right is
this unique to humans that's a great
question I mean the thing is that animal
fairness is something that cuts across
all the animals that actually have a
social system that can track these sorts
of things so the most famous example is
um a study by Sarah Brosnan in Fran's de
Waal and what they did is they trained
these um capuchin monkeys to play this
game where they would give the monkey a
pebble it would return the pebble and
they would give it a slice of cucumber
and so we know that the monkey regarded
payment of a cucumber slice as fair
because it actually learned the behavior
and returned for a cucumber but now what
they do in the critical point in the
experiment is they have another monkey
in the cage next to them and when that
monkey returns the pebble instead of
giving it a cucumber like they were like
the first monkey got they reward it with
a great well monkeys they far prefer
grapes over cucumbers and so then the
question is what is our original monkey
do you now that it sees another one
getting a grape for the very same
behavior in which is being paid in
cucumbers well when they then try to
reward that animal with cucumbers it
gets really upset and often rejects the
cucumber who refuses to take it and this
is a great video that do-all has where
he's giving a TED talk and you can see
the monkey literally throw the cucumber
at the exponent as he's like it's it's a
wonderful example of an animals sense of
fairness now I don't think that they
think of fairness quite the same way
that we do I think that would be
anthropomorphizing but what I do think
is happening is that they're going well
I cannot accept a reward this less than
the reward the other one gets around
being left behind and of course it's not
doing that consciously but that's
nonetheless the psychology that
underlies its rejection of an
that it previously thought was just fine
yeah I guess it's it's a very nuanced
thing to be able to understand comparing
different you know your car versus my
motorbike your house versus my boat you
know that's very very nuanced and that's
subtle that humans you know whereas
that's you know great grape versus
cucumber I think yeah he has basic yeah
absolutely
so I know that I discussed this with
Robin Hanson and he had he knows that
this is such a contested area about how
monogamous the particular individuals
were around about this sort of time
where does your current opinion lie with
regards to monogamy within these these
developmental tribes so if you there's
lots of variability you've got um trot
you've got groups of people who clearly
showed up very little signs of monogamy
and then you've got groups of people
where you've got basically just monogamy
and of course you've got polygyny as
well my intuition I don't know this but
I believe it is that basically our
ancestors were on average serially
monogamous with a little bit of
shenanigans along the way and so what we
see quite commonly in hunter-gatherers
is monogamous pairing that lasts for
anywhere from you know very briefly to
seven or eight years even or sometimes
even for life but usually not forever
and they sort of eventually go their own
ways and then repair up with somebody
else I think that system was super
common because it gains you advantage of
not putting all your genetic eggs in one
basket and you know when times change
maybe somebody else's genes would be a
better fit for the new world and um it
it's consistent with our modern
psychology that it's it's easier to
maintain passion for somebody when
they're new then then when you've been
with them for a long time but I don't
think that polygyny was a super common
system or any kind of polyamorous system
and the best evidence for that I think
is is literally the size of our
testicles if you if you look at the
testicles of all the great apes you know
gorillas have very small testicles
because they maintain a harem physically
with the their body strength they don't
compete with no other male is having sex
with their females so and it does
actually take that much sperm to
inseminate a female so they can
small testicles chimpanzees have
enormous testicles because everybody's
having sex with her when she when she
becomes fertile yeah and so they
basically need to wash out the guy
before them and have sperm competition
where their sperm gets there first and
then human beings our testicles are
closer to a gorilla than a chimp but
they're way larger than a gorilla okay
and that tells me that that we're we're
using where there is some sperm
competition in our ancestral history but
nothing like the level that we see in
chimpanzees there's an argument to be
made as well about penis shape right
that it creates a vacuum is that correct
yeah that's a great question I don't
totally know our Scenic's the experiment
and I've seen this sort of penis plunger
system it's super possible right it's
it's all these things evolve and and in
our case our penises are way larger than
the other great apes and of course we
copulate with for much longer than most
of the primates do you know there's
exceptions with bonobos who have these
constant orgies but human beings when
they copulate do so for a long period of
time they do so when the female is not
currently fertile because of course
she's hidden her fertility signals
ovulation is cryptic in humans we can't
tell and so and that gets human males to
be interested in human females across
the cycle because otherwise they might
be left out and of course that makes
both sides engage in greater pair
bonding which makes good sense when you
look at the difficulty of raising human
babies to adulthood they take a lot of
work by both parents yeah and so I
suspect that the penis may well be
designed to try to help suction out the
guy ahead of them but but probably the
primary purpose is for bonding so that
they have a good time together and
copulation can take quite a while and so
I think the reason our penis is so large
is sexual selection that that's what's
human females prefer and so that's what
human males are like and that's why of
course we're so obsessed with it and the
ideal outcome of the outcome that
evolution was wanting us to arrive at
was great a pair bonding here right it
was a high level of investment between
each other is that correct yes so the
when you have a system like ours where
it takes so much effort to raise a human
you know a dozen years minimally to get
them to be a reasonably effective unit
who can forage for itself that takes a
lot of care and and takes two parents to
achieve that and it is the case that
relatives also often work together so
particularly herb her family will play a
big role in helping raise the kids and
we see this in all sorts of places but I
do believe that part of what also
underlies that is pair bonding and his
willingness to look out for her and help
her in return for her fidelity and so I
think that's a deal that that humans
made somewhere along the way it's not
it's not a mission-critical deal for our
intelligence or our social intelligence
because I do think that's more happening
at the group level but I but it does
appear to me to be the deal that we did
strike well it makes the most sense that
the man cannot raise the child among
can't get pregnant so they have to focus
on what they can do and right every both
sides what can you what can you bring to
the table and you have to remember that
female the obligatory investment of a
male the minimal investment he can put
into a child is you know a teaspoon of
sperm the minimal investment she can put
it into a child is you know nine months
of gestation and in ancestral Society
he's two years of lactation well that's
a huge investment compared to his and as
Trevor's has shown us in the early 1970s
in this parental investment model that
means that on average men will compete
very fiercely for females because it's
of course they're competing for her
investment yes yeah I totally get that
so were there any other any of the
discoveries that you came across while
you were writing the book and
researching it that you found that we're
really surprising
well what's surprising but to me is how
many implications it has so I'd be
working on the book and then I would get
a friend or a colleague who would say
hey can you come give a talk about
leadership or about happiness or about
innovation and I would say well I don't
work on that and they would say well but
surely what you're doing must have
implications for it and said stay home
let me think about it and it always did
every time somebody came with one of
those requests I would give it a little
bit of fun I say well wait really does
have implications for when and why we
innovate for how we lead for what makes
us happy and so from
the surprise was just how socially
psychologically rich it is to understand
and to think a lot about where we came
from because it tells us a fair bit
about why we are the way we are today
yeah I think one of the one of the
definite conclusions that our drew from
my conversation with Professor Robin
Hanson was that the world around us has
moved an awful lot quicker than our
evolution can catch up with and I think
we kid ourselves into believing that
we're a lot more sophisticated and a lot
more in control a lot more in control of
our unconscious mind than we would care
to believe and you know when you you're
talking about you say 80 thousand years
ago was when there was a fairly big
split off and there was only ten
thousand years ago I think in in and
around the Philippines and stuff where
there was the final last non sapiens
homo species is that right the miniature
diminutive size in Florence ah yeah I
don't know exactly when they were when
that their last stand was I have to
admit I'm not sure about that but I'm I
suspect you right I suspect that numbers
correct certainly we were interacting
with Neanderthals twenty and thirty
thousand years ago and probably for
quite a long time right given that we so
for example the first Australians
arrived 65 thousand years ago well but
if we got to Australia sixty-five
thousand years ago we'd covered a fair
bit of Asia and Europe by then too we've
had a lot of interaction with
Neanderthals by then and presumably with
Denisovans and others and what what
those others might be of course we don't
know but there probably was a lot of
intermixing and a lot of interesting
blending because really we're
interacting with cousins so to speak you
know our ancestors some of them left
some stayed sapiens happens to be a
product of those who stayed but we ran
into blended product with those who left
yeah do you ever imagine what it would
be like if we'd if there was still
megafauna around megafauna or animals or
if the if Neanderthals had managed to
hold on or if there was multiple
different homo subspecies floating
around now do you ever sort of fantasize
about that or think about what it would
be like
I do and I I worry that the story would
not be a positive one because we're so
tribal already when it's just other
groups of humans who basically are the
same as us but with some very slight
appearance differences it's easy for me
to imagine we could be really awful with
people who really are distinctly
different species and it's easy you know
given that that there aren't any left
I suspect we were awful with them that
we're super effective and when we're not
positively disposed for others we don't
use that super effectiveness for good
right we use it to exterminate them or
genocide will toward each other and so
if maybe if there were still all sorts
of cousin species in the world it would
be a an easier pleasant lovely place but
I have the bad feeling it wouldn't yeah
I'm tempted to agree but I do think
oddly enough the two conversations I've
had with yourself and and professor
Hanson very strangely I feel liberated
when I hear them I I think a lot of the
time we beat ourselves up about being it
less in control of our unconscious mind
and our actions and our motivations than
we wish that we were we get frustrated
when we're in traffic and we get scared
when we hear loud noises
you know with all of the emotions that
we feel loneliness and depression and
anxiety and everything both positive and
negative
just artifact of a time that we evolved
in that no longer exists and we're kind
of trying to make this primitive brain
fitter modern world now that's
absolutely right because the greatest
invention that we ever had was this idea
of cumulative culture of learning from
each other of communicating that
information over great times and
distances and that moves so quickly and
we're such generalists that we have the
capacity to do that but as you point out
that doesn't mean that our brain changes
it anywhere near that speed it just
doesn't and so the things that make us
happy the things that scare us
those those early things are still in
there and I guess what I would argue is
the important thing to remember is that
we're not totally at their mercy right
they don't control us but they are an
important nudge that pushes us to feel
jealous sometimes to misbehave other
times and the key is to stop and ask
yourself well why
my feeling this way and why am I being
so aggressive toward so-and-so and why
am I not happy with what I've got here
when I used to be and ask yourself those
questions and I do think that we can
retake some of that control simply by
virtue of the power of our frontal
cortex so to speak and and and trying to
say well I can't let myself just be
buffeted around by my unconscious mind
which really evolved a long time ago and
is much better suited to a world that
doesn't exist anymore
I totally get that the race to the
bottom of the brainstem so to speak
needs to be counteracted I did a yes
with meditation expert Cory Allen and
he's got this wonderful term that I love
using called the mindfulness gap and he
talks about in between the action
occurring which you need to react to and
your reaction is this mindfulness gap
and that one breath that two breaths in
between it can make such a profound
change and you know that probably
wouldn't be that useful if you're out in
the plains you want to be like a boxer
you want to react before you even think
where is now obviously being able to
step in between ourselves and our
reactions it's actually quite a useful
skill no that's absolutely right because
of course we no longer solve our
problems physically where speed is of
the essence we now solve our problems
much more by negotiation and verbally
and so if given that you're better off
not necessarily flying off the handle
right away and giving your immediate
response but saying well hold on and I
love that term mindfulness gap I've not
heard that but yeah Cory is super smart
so I'm not surprised it's it's
absolutely perfect I think so the final
question that I wanted to ask I'm aware
that you're unable to answer this with
any real certainty but at the moment
we're moving forward towards a world of
AI development and you know that the
world is changing so quickly that I
suppose any genetic mutations which were
which did provide any particular
advantages would have to be so generally
applicable that they're probably not
going to stick because of how fast the
environments moving the environment now
is different to it was 150 years ago and
so on and so forth so if you were to if
you were to put your money where your
mouth is have you got any idea about
whether we're going to see a different
homo species before
you know is it gonna be 500,000 years
it's gonna be a million years can you
predict what would happen here to put
your money money down well that's a
great question and I'd be happy to
predict it because I know neither of us
will be here to find out if I'm wrong
and so I'll the oldest ad with great
confidence but in truth you know our
species is a new one Homo erectus lasted
for almost two million years and we've
only been around for two or three
hundred thousand you know it's hard to
make an exact beginning point because of
course it was a continuous process and
then the question is is our incredible
effectiveness going to be our undoing or
is it going to make us a huge success
and literally you can't tell right now
right it could easily blow us all up we
could develop a wonderful AI system than
some random psychopath reprograms to
kill us all there's a there's a million
ways that could go wrong and only a few
ways that it could go right and we're
trying to trick this sort of as you call
her this this this primitive brain of
ours into living in this super
complicated super diverse modern world
so my my suspicion is that if you fast
forwarded a few hundred thousand years
we've got a 50% chance that haven't been
really lucky and we're now basically
biologically the same that we are now
although we've done all sorts of tweaks
to make ourselves live longer and we're
probably a little cyborgs like machine
enhanced and all that kind of stuff yeah
but you know I I also worry a lot that
that we don't get anywhere near that far
because we just do ourselves in either
with our own inventions that we're about
to come up with that will then take over
or or just blow ourselves up because
that risk was always there and it's come
close many times yeah I think I did a
podcast with Professor Adam Frankie
wrote light of us stars and he
identified that one of the byproducts of
any world girdling civilization is going
to be the level of global warming that
we have because you can't have the
energy you need for this civilization
without the byproduct of the greenhouse
gases and so on and so forth and then if
you read super intelligence with a
fantastic book on on AI by Professor
Nick Bostrom from the future humanities
Institute of Oxford
you know if there's so many different
ways that we can [ __ ] this up like many
from ways and it's nearly infinite hello
and it's bizarre it's so bizarre to
think that if evolution hadn't if
evolution hadn't created that mutation
that took us from Homo erectus to homo
sapiens the homo species may have lasted
an awful lot longer so bizarre to think
that you can ooh oh shoot
brain capacity to the point where it
becomes dangerously proficient and that
can actually be your downfall right in
the irony is that it's the combination
of individual brains and our incredible
capacity to connect them to each other
because you know I don't think a human
on the planet could make an iPhone but a
lot of us obviously can make iPhones and
when we all tweaked it together which we
that's what made us so successful in the
savanna was our capacity to work
together and that capacity could be the
the irony is that that which saved us
could easily be our undoing
yeah that's so fascinating I have got a
final question before we go sure one of
my friends mentioned it before he
mentioned that a lot of people enjoy the
smell of fresh grass and wondered
whether or not that was harking back to
the fact that being out on the plains
was a natural habitat for us it's very
very difficult to work it but I thought
that was an interesting an interesting
thought that you know this yeah it's a
great question because the what are our
natural proclivities you know I argue
that we all enjoy throwing rocks because
even from very young age because
throwing stones was so important for our
ancestors and even into Homo sapiens
lots of modern lots of human cultures
until very recent times still used stone
throwing very effectively and so the
smell of grass is another example where
that's a natural habitat for us it
there's um some very interesting work
that talks about what makes a scene
beautiful and what makes a place look
stand out as a lovely place to live and
they have Ellucian arguments are that
things that afford us a wide view we
like that because we could see enemies
coming at us things that forests that
are likely to have lots of game all
those kinds of things are our
preferences that if our ancestors had it
would have made them more successful now
they you raise an interesting one this
idea of freshly cut grass or just grass
in general and
I suppose that makes good sense because
of course grass is a very unique species
in the sense that it can dry out the
roots are still alive but their animals
won't be there but once grass goes once
it rains and the grass goes green again
the animals tend to gather and so we may
have evolved a proclivity to like the
color and the smell of fresh growing
grass because it's a good sign that
dinner must be around the corner yes so
fascinating so what you're saying is
that in terms of creating a nice
landscape or a scenery potentially out
of the back of a five to fancy five-star
hotel that the interior designers of the
landscape designers need to be calling
an evolutionary biologists and and
psychologists to then come and consult
and they can say well though it there
wouldn't be it there wouldn't be enough
Buffalo over the far side so I don't
really think that we can have that lake
in that area exactly and if they pay us
a lot it'll work out better for
everybody
fantastic well that's brilliant and Bill
would you be able to tell the listeners
where they can find you online please
certainly so at this point I'm the
easiest way to find me is simply the
Google bill or william von Hippel vo nhi
ppl my book the social leap is available
now in the States and will be available
soon in the UK and is becoming available
lots of other places as well and so
googling either of those two things is
the best bet I've set up a website for
the book but it's so rudimentary at this
point I would ignore it that's fine I'll
make sure that the link to all of your
content is in the show notes below I'll
make sure it's the social leaf is
available in the UK on the 27th of
December so as I'm lounging around next
to the Christmas tree eating the
remainder of my chocolates I know what
I'm going to be reading I can't thank
you enough for coming on bill it's been
absolutely fascinating I thought I feel
like we could have gone on for four
hours an hours so we may need to we may
need to come back and give it another
round - in the new year but I hope that
your book tour continues to be very
successful in the US will you be back in
will you be back in oz in time for
Christmas no I won't I won't get back to
Australia until February because we're
covering a lot of ground but I will get
to the UK briefly my sister lives in
London and so and my daughter goes to
school in Wales and so it's my hope to
be
noodling around there a bit as well and
it's been lots of fun chatting with you
and I look forward to doing so again
amazing you'll have to drop me a message
once you're in the UK and if I can if I
can come down and meet you for a coffee
that would be fantastic
perfect cheers bill thank you very much
for your time
good to talk to you
[Music]
you